there are some pictures that came out
um
that showed Islam makachev the guy who
just fought Alexander volkanowski uh and
I you know Volk is our boy we love we
love Volk and this is why we're talking
about this obviously yes we're biased we
want to protect bulk but there's some
images that came back that showed Islam
with a bruise on a part of his arm where
a vein would be
now that bruise
is a typical bruise for someone who has
received an IV you're not allowed to
rehydrate with an IV there's a two-year
suspension for that they look at it like
performance enhancing drugs because in a
lot of ways it is you've depleted your
body with so much water to make weight
and now you found a way to get all that
water back into it before the fight and
the only way to do it at that speed is
to just have it done intravenously oh
yeah I did an IV drip the other day that
[__] was I saw you wonderful and you
have a little sore on the arm yep okay
yeah so I look at these images and I was
like look this could be photoshopped
right there's also a video from the
UFC's embedded show now embed is where
they do the remember the 24 7 Floyd
Mayweather type things they follow the
fighters so they have video of him I
think it's before the fight where you
also see the wound I think you have the
video dude yeah so you also see the the
black and blue now he's also a boxer I
don't want to say this as a fact that's
what I'm saying he's also not a box he's
also a fighter you could get bruises
maybe that's a part where you've got to
bruise there are other options here the
only problem is
that
there are rumors swirling that the woman
that administered the IV
has spoken to people and said that she
did it where did he get the IV do we
know if it's in Australia yes he's there
because Dan hooker tweeted about it and
he was like it's yeah Dan hooker tweeted
but it's after the weigh-in so he hooker
was like do you really think that you
could get an IV in Australia we wouldn't
find out I do actually it's a big
country I I don't no but they run you're
you're fighting a HomeTown hero that's
true you got to bring your people in to
do that now I think to me the only
reason why I wouldn't believe this is
because I can't imagine that somebody or
somebody's team is so mind-bogglingly
stupid yeah that they would just risk it
with a random IV company that's the most
disciplined people on the world like
they're gonna go on Google and be like
IVs in my area send them over and also
you're the most recognized there's
nobody that's got only beard hair Here
Lady probably works for Twitter too
snitching snitching yeah but she won't
come out she's kind of like thorough
she's she's basically they're basically
like yo are you gonna just come out and
just say that he did this she said I
don't want to deal with the backlash I
don't want to deal with everything
that's going on but I have spoken to
some people that have you know
however on decent Authority that they
may have spoken her and that's what's
being claimed now this is huge one the
UFC does not want this you don't want a
controversy about making weight two they
would have to suspend him for two
[__] years yeah you don't want one of
your stars that you're calling them a
pound guy to be a cheat and then three
this not only tarnishes his legacy but
does it tarnish
the whole Camp yeah start looking at the
rest of the people in the camp and then
going how much does IV do
if you're cutting if you're cutting a
lot of weight think about how much you
got to dehydrate yourself to be 15
pounds lighter than you normally are
when you're already that fit yeah two
and it helps in two ways one all your
cardio goes not all but a lot your
cardio significantly is reduced when you
take all the water out of your body your
body's just so depleted but two you're
easier to get knocked out so your chin
goes without that water so being able to
rehydrate and get back to normal be able
to have the cardio but also be able to
withstand punches is
unfathomably important in a fight huge
advantage and especially when you're a
guy who's cutting weight to have an
advantage yeah that's why it's a
two-year suspension think about that I
think for like a drug it's one or even
less it's such an advantage in a fight
that the suspensions for two especially
if you're coming up and he's coming down
the one advantage you have is he's
coming down a lot he's going to get
tired he's going to get gas otherwise if
you can go right back to that level of
strength and endurance you're [__]
it's going right back to that 30 pound
advantage or whatever right I don't yeah
as far as casting doubt on the rest of
the camp though like what I'm I I don't
necessarily do that but what I'm saying
is that's what happens like when there's
one cheat within an organization you
assume like if Lance Armstrong is
cheating you're like well aren't all the
yeah Jose Canseco God pop for steroids
was like I was giving them to everybody
that's just what you and it makes sense
you're like yeah and then you're dealing
with like that's why I'm saying if Islam
did this
if and again this is a rumor I can't
confirm any of this and I'm also very
like delicate with even saying these
things because this is this person's
livelihood this is you know he he ended
up getting a decision over a guy who's
our boy that we love but at the same
time it's like we gotta be delicate with
these rumors until it's true these are
rumors but there's a lot of evidence
that looks like there's some shady [__]
and this is for sure because I'm looking
at some of these pictures and it looks
like it could be camp pictures like from
Camp does this video for sure is after
the weigh-in before the fight yep okay
because yeah there is a spot there
because I was thinking some of those
pictures could just be normal camp
training gloves I can't believe that
they didn't just put some [__]
I can't believe they didn't just put
some what's it called on a makeup or
whatever because I'm saying wear a long
sleeve shirt it seems so obvious that
you would think that it's not that yeah
but yeah that's that's the other thing
it's like if you were really worried or
concerned about it you would wear a long
sleeve shirt you would try to find hide
it the fact that he's not trying to hide
it almost makes me go like okay maybe
this is a misunderstanding maybe he got
an iv for something else maybe they had
to take blood for a blood test right
maybe usada was like hey we need to but
then that nurse would kind of be smart
enough to say I gave him a blood test
exactly that's the only thing that's
tricky but then we don't have a nurse
though exactly there is allegedly a
nurse who's saying that this did happen
but won't come out yeah and that's a big
[__] allegedly yeah you know and it
sucks because the fight was so
incredible
yeah so it like it was just you know
folk is the men amazing and I honestly
I'm not mad at the decision I kind of
scored it 3-2 as well I again I'm very
much a novice but I thought I thought it
all came out in the second round and I
thought novice opinion he had more like
time with bulk on the ground even though
Volk wasn't like phased by it so I could
be wrong but that's how I had it this is
a great fight the fact that it was just
so close it was like I I couldn't really
tell at the end yeah yeah yeah I
wouldn't be mad either way but uh with a
decision but there is a new way that
we're gonna have to look at scoring for
fights like just holding somebody in a
dominant position without doing anything
it's like Volk was doing these punches
and he was punching uh what's his face
markja behind his head is there a lot of
power on those punches maybe not would
we like to get hit with them now
definitely not right but to me that's
more damage than someone just being a
backpack right and not inflicting any
pain whatsoever so it's like if you
score those punches
as more than the holding that person in
a dominant position yeah
then I see why you would give the round
to Vulcan then Vogue wins yeah yeah the
scoring really dictates strategy that if
you just have to be in a dominant or
winning position for the majority of the
fight it's like yeah I'll just try to
hold you yeah I'll just work on ground I
don't really need to work on striking
which is sort of the strategy of the
camp it seems like yeah I mean Jude
vocal is just so impressive he's also
just a classy dude yeah and also I would
say uh Islam's response was also cool
like I thought both of them they both
gave it up I loved that there was like a
nice fight where they both clearly
respect each other even before round
five they dapped each other up bro folk
I don't know if you saw this when Islam
was had his hand raised the crowd start
to boo and you can see vulk in the
background like no cut it out go on yo
chill don't do that like the guy's
[__] pure class he really is but also
what he is is an unbelievable athlete
that was bringing a pain to to Islam
like if that's a street fight Islam's
not making it home yeah like he's
exhausted at the end looking for the
clock every two [__] seconds Volk
looks like it's the first [__] round
yeah like he's the smaller guy who
couldn't be out wrestled couldn't be
choked out all the things that Islam has
just absolutely dominated people doing
and it's like this [__] is not
to be played with and Islam gave it up
to him yeah 100 what I will say about
Islam was that his distance management
was phenomenal I've never seen Volk look
like he was extending himself too much
to land a punch and granted Islam is
taller but Volks fought taller guys but
Islam managed the distance so well that
when Volk was striking he had to take
real risk to get in that yeah I was
getting nervous yeah and it's like I got
to give Islam Credit in America but I
think if they run it back I think
vulcan's that easy yeah and I hope he
doesn't get suspended so they can run it
back I hope that that's not true it's
just for the sake of the sport and for
the sake of Volk like going in there
against somebody who's got like an
illegal Advantage like and then lose
losing that fight they would take away
the L but like I'd rather you just
didn't put your body on the line five
months of your life for however many
months the camp is for like oh it's all
kind of [__] yeah yeah it sucks but
it's also a good turnout for him
regardless like you know omitting the
you know conspiracy angle with that you
lose but you lose on a technicality you
lose on points but you win in spirit
yeah and you lose in a fight that a lot
of people like Rogan apparently thought
Volk one yep so that says something yeah
it's funny UFC is trying to call it
Islam the pound for pound number one now
yeah I don't see that that was never up
for grabs for him in my opinion it makes
Volk pound for pound if he comes up and
wait and beats the bigger guy yeah it
doesn't make you be pound for pound if
you're fighting the smaller guy you're
your Defender
he's going for the Challenger yeah you
get to keep your belt but you don't gain
more yeah I think if you come up you're
taking the challenge and if you beat
that person one division up it's like oh
this guy is so no trade-off is you have
a lot to gain but you're at a
disadvantage because you're coming up
exactly it still makes you pound for
pound if you're used to fighting at a
certain weight and you have to drop more
than you normally have to drop
it oh he's awake oh okay I'm sorry I
thought they Oh I thought he bought more
too yeah no no they like that's one
thing with the IV thing like if he
didn't come down more than he normally
is like why is this recovery so much
worse and why did he have to do this if
this is normal cut and that's why I'm
kind of like I don't whatever that means
he would be bigger than normal
he yeah he was probably he either wasn't
training as hard or wasn't monitoring
the food as much or what happens is as
you get older you start to hold on to
the weight and cutting that water weight
is [__] hard they say this boxers
it's like they used to be able to take
off the 20 pounds in water weight and
towards the end of their careers they
just can't do it they just don't shed so
I mean the guy's probably been cutting
weight since he was doing wrestling is
like a [__] thing yeah eight-year-old
yeah so you know when you talk about
Volks cardio what I thought about uh and
we obviously we love easiest maybe one
of my favorite athletes in the world but
when he fought Jan I think was his name
that yeah he went up yep Beyond just
leaning on Izzy you see Izzy get tired
after rounds yep and obviously is he's
one of the greatest athletes on Earth
Volk had this a similar thing maybe not
the same weight difference yeah but
similar thing just getting leaned on
getting held on the ground and wasn't
remotely fatigued I have a mind boggles
I have a theory about that okay he comes
from Aussie rules rugby right you talked
about yes where he was weighing much
more I think he was weighing over 200
pounds but also they run like 10 miles
amount stop running you'll never see
guys that size with that good cardio
they're just even football is stop and
go yes Prince but the Aussie is constant
right so it's like I think cardio for a
guy like folk obviously he works really
hard at it but having that background
where it was just non-stop and it's
physical it's physical with cardio it's
not like soccer I feel like that
physical yeah but you're like tackling
the [__] out of each other yeah so the
cardio for him that's just what yeah
it's just a lesser version of what I do
and I'm lighter now hell yeah I was
however 40 40 pounds heavier back then
yeah running like that now I'm lighter
this is light work I think weirdly in a
loss he solidifies himself as pound for
pound you might be right the weirdest
thing that happens but it's like you
came up you fought the most dangerous
guy in the UFC so to say and some people
think you beat him yeah it was without a
doubt a very close fight you finish the
fight in the dominant position mm-hmm
but you can't take pound per pound until
you do it like just because you feel
like it was number one is the thing I'm
sorry to interrupt but he's not trying
to go from two to one he was number one
right so I think he holds his spot and
tells him out he takes it from him I
don't think Islam took it from them no
no of course but I'm saying like if the
whole claim is like oh double bell champ
pound for pound
you can't really be that until you do it
which if they rematch I think he'll do
it oh I didn't say he was the double
belt right but you're saying power pound
and I'm like you're not pounding pound
until you win the fight against the guy
at a different weight class had become
pound per pound I don't know if that
makes you powerful because he was pound
for pound before when he never fought
the guy in different weight class but
that was still
basically it's like you can't say who
the most
who the best fighter is because the
bigger Fighters could just absolutely
destroy a smaller fighter yeah so pound
for pound is basically saying
this is the best person if we look at
all no no if we looked at all fighters
almost equally
no we can't because heavyweights have
such an advantage like a heavyweight
fighting a guy at 155 pounds one punch
on the top of it had like a cartoon
but a guy who's but if we look at them
evenly like Floyd was the number one
pound for pound he couldn't be a
heavyweight but he was so dominant
within his weight classes that we go his
skill is the best oh [__] I've always
looked at that wrong I thought pound
means like you've moved a couple of
weight classes and you were the dominant
person in those ways I thought you have
to be at least two different weight
classes
what happens is when you move weight
you prove your dominance yeah so it
helps it but it's not a requirement it's
like in basketball if they did in for
inch Allen Iverson might be the best
player ever because he's five nine or
whatever oh that's yeah he was so
[__] good Jordan's a better player
but Jordan was six six so like yeah it
can't really measure those dudes you
know it would be like inch for inch in
NBA yeah so powerful pound is just like
it's an opinion it kind of favors
smaller guys but it's an opinion thing
that absolutely does well UFC does do an
official ranking for pound for pound
yeah yeah which is like excited by
people though yeah it seems like it
started as like Barbershop type [__] and
then UFC was like why don't we just make
this a thing which is smart yeah yeah
that's funny in boxing I always thought
it was an official but that you can like
see on paper yeah all this ranking [__]
is yeah just humans